hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter six of his work tragic sense
of life miguel de uno muno
is going to invoke what he calls
passionate doubt and you could also
call this existential doubt
as well as a sort of comportment but
passionate
is is nice because although he doesn't
actually
bring up too many of the passions in
that particular
section he does continually throughout
the work
and the passions or the emotions the
affectivity and the will
the heart as he calls it in other places
are going to be
involved in the sort of doubt that he is
talking about
and he differentiates it or
distinguishes it
early on in that chapter from cartesian
doubt and cartesian doubt
could be a stand-in for all sorts of
other things he's going to
target descartes but we could just as
easily talk about
you know human skepticism and the sort
of doubt that that goes along with that
which hume thinks we can't actually
bring out into the real world by the way
we leave it behind when we enter the
billiard room it could be the doubt of
so many other people it could be
anything which is a largely intellectual
a theoretical a uncommitted
sort of doubt one which does not
actually provoke
any feelings or require any
interestingly
commitments on our part it's a doubt
that can be
reduced as he says to a method which is
what descartes does and what so many
other
people employing doubt in that way do
it involves a kind of suspension of
belief or
ascent a bracketing if you like
right and as he says there it has little
vitalizing force what does that mean
it means that it really doesn't have
much of an effect within our life
it has little to offer us
other than intellectual stimulation and
perhaps uh you know some usefulness as a
methodological
tool so what can we
distinguish from this
you know overly rationalist kind
of doubting well passionate doubt he
says
and he begins the chapter by saying that
the vital longing for human immortality
which is what the whole book is
centering around right
and it's not just human immortality in
the sense of am i going to go to heaven
or go to hell or something like that
it's is there a point to life is all of
this
just going to disappear into nothingness
myself included but also the entire
cosmos
or is there anything that's actually
going to be
preserved and can we know this can we
know it one way or the other
or are we stuck in a sort of vacillating
between the two of them
never really knowing but still having to
make decisions that's the case
that he thinks that we're in so he says
this vital longing for human immortality
finds no consolation
in reason reason leaves us without
incentive or consolation in life and
life itself without
real finality but here in the depths of
the abyss
the despair of the heart and of the will
and the skepticism of reason
meet face to face and embrace like
brothers now isn't that a wonderful
phrase both the side of rationality the
intellect
reason carried through not just in the
individual but in entire
programs and traditions we might say
that entire side ultimately leads us
to well doesn't seem like there is
anything that's going to survive
and even reason itself is rather a
contingent
development this sounds a little bit
like nietzsche at this this point right
and also the despair of the heart and of
the will
both of those meet in this passionate
doubt
he says skepticism uncertainty the
position to which reason by practicing
its analysis upon itself
upon its own validity validity at last
arrives
that is the foundation upon which the
heart's despair must build up
its hope so hope and doubt
are going to go in some respect hand in
hand
you hope precisely because you don't
know
right so this passion of doubt
is going to be quite different and a
little bit later on he talks about it as
being
raised by eternal conflicts
he says that this is the skepticism the
insertitude
that he's talking about here this other
doubt is a passionate doubt
it is the eternal conflict between
reason
and feeling science and life
logic and biotic biotic coming from the
word for
life a certain structure that life
itself
requires and this is you know an eternal
challenge for
philosophers to make sense of it's very
easy to like go on the side of reason
and then exclude everything that doesn't
fit into that that's sort of like the
metaphor
of the person who's looking for his car
keys and you know his friend says well
you know have you found him and he's i'm
searching under this uh
street light here and the friend says is
that where you lost your car keys
and the guy says no i actually lost him
over there but the light is so much
better over here
that's a terrible way to look for
anything isn't it it restricts you to
where you're not going to find what
you're you're actually seeking so he
says
science destroys the concept of
personality by reducing it to a complex
and continual flux from moment to moment
and this doubt cannot avail itself as
he's going to say
of any provisional ethic what does he
mean by a provisional ethic
well he has in mind here descartes again
descartes he says was a little bit
inconsistent in that he claimed to doubt
everything
but he did have a provisional ethic
which he describes in
you know part three of the discourse he
says that uh
i'll back up to that a little bit it
says
descartes was saying as it's not enough
before beginning to rebuild one's
dwelling house to pull it down and
furnish materials and architects
or study architecture oneself it's also
necessary to be provided with some other
wherein to lodge conveniently while the
work is in progress
he framed for himself a provisional
ethic
the first law of which was was to
observe the customs of his country
and keep always the religion which by
the grace of god he'd been instructed by
infancy
governing himself in all things
according to most moderate
opinions and you know that's certainly
something one can do
one can say well we're gonna
intellectually doubt things and then
we'll have our
world of practice over here and of
course we need to keep like paying our
taxes and
being good neighbors and you know
filling in all the forms and doing all
the things that we're supposed to do
even though intellectually we can doubt
all of this we can say maybe none of
this even exists
there's a there's a disconnect there
isn't there
unamuno says no no we can't have a
provisional ethics like that
why because reason is going to tear that
down as well
and it really is not going to appeal
that well to the heart
what do we need to have then he says we
have to found
our ethic on the conflict
now that's a very interesting
phrase isn't it he says it has to found
its ethic
on the conflict an ethic of battle and
it has to serve as the foundation of
religion it inhabits a house which is
continually being demolished
and which it continually has to rebuild
without ceasing the will
the will never to die the spirit of
unsubmissiveness to death
it labors to build up the house of life
and without ceasing the keen blasts and
stormy assaults of reason
beat it down and so you know
what what's going on there it sounds
like he's taking the side against reason
which we're going to get to in just a
moment
but what would an ethic of this battle
consistent so he's talking about the
need to continually rebuild
we could call this an ethic of
perseverance
an ethic of going back
at it even though we encounter failures
even though we encounter setbacks we
keep on trying to build something
that we can dwell in as human beings
that's an important part of it another
important part would be
trying to find if not necessarily a
balance
or you know lines of demarcation between
rationality and everything else
trying to do justice to these within
ourselves
it's sort of like listening to
squabbling people all of whom are
talking at the same time
and trying to meet their needs or
address the complaints that they're
making against each other
it's going to be an imperfect thing it's
going to be a continual
synthesis that we're carrying out
now we can ask is this going to be an
outright rejection of re
reason rationality science
all the intellectual side and it sounds
at first as if he is endorsing
something like that right
he says that the concrete vital problem
that concerns us
reason has no position whatsoever in
truth it does something
worse than deny the immortality of the
soul for that would be at least one
solution
it refuses even to recognize the problem
as our vital desire
presents it to us in the rational and
logical sense of the term problem
there is no such problem it falls
outside of reason
and since it falls outside of reason
reason doesn't really care about it
and then he appeals to kierkegaard and
this
may in fact make you think oh yeah this
is going to be quite
irrationalist especially since he brings
up how kierkegaard
is engaging in you know intense passion
a bitter invective against hegel
prototype of the rationalist
now interestingly una muno says at that
point when he says what bitter invective
that is to say truth so he he really
does seem to be endorsing that
he says though i doubt whether our
brother kierkegaard is
all together in the right for this same
abstract thinker or thinker of
abstractions thinks in order he may
exist
or he may not cease to exist or thinks
perhaps in order that he
will forget he he will have to cease to
exist and the this is the root of the
passion for abstract thought now this is
an interesting point
as well so abstract thought
reason has its own passions that it's
driven by it's not entirely
disinterested objective or anything like
that there
are deeper roots this is a common
existentialist position
as well a little bit later on
we see a little bit of balance being
restored although it's not really
balanced
it's not even equilibrium he says that
faith life and reason have mutual need
of each other we we can't get away
from them he says this vital longing is
not
properly a problem it cannot assume a
logical status
cannot be formulated in propositions
susceptible of rational discussion
so that sounds pretty bad at that point
but
we can feel it again passionate
doubt we can feel it he says
it announces itself in us as hunger
announces
itself do you ever like you know think
to yourself
i i wonder if i'm hungry i should
consult my body
to find out okay there we go oh my body
says that i'm at
exactly 47 capacity and i should
probably
eat some some sugars and carbohydrates
and
you know hopefully some proteins to have
longer no is that how your body works
right you feel hungry you might take
stimulants so that you don't feel hungry
like
you know certain kinds of amphetamines
you know caffeine is an appetite
suppressant
um but you know in general your body is
going to tell you if you're hungry if
you're real sick maybe you're not hungry
as well
but we get to know that we're hungry by
suddenly feeling hungry
sometimes it creeps up and it reaches a
certain threshold and now we suddenly
feel it
that's the same thing with so many of
our other passions or
our desires or our aversions isn't it
you know we're in a place and suddenly
we realize that things stink and we need
to get the hell out of there
or we're with a person and suddenly our
our hairs stand up on end and we're like
this
this person's sketchy right those are
the sorts of things that we
we feel and so he says
neither can the wolf that throws itself
with the fury on hunger upon its prayer
with the fury of instinct upon the
she-wolf
enunciate it's an impulse rationally as
a logical problem
reason and faith are two enemies neither
of which can maintain itself
without the other
isn't that an interesting twist right
reason and faith are two enemies
neither of which can endure the other
put up with the other
no neither of which can maintain itself
without the other
the irrational he says demands to be
rationalized and reason
can only operate on the irrational they
are compelled to seek out mutual support
and association but association and
struggle for struggle is a mode of
association
if we want to use sort of old tv things
we could say that they're the odd couple
right they're perpetually at odds and
yet they have to live together
and find some sort of modus vivendi
that will allow them not to strangle
each other or throw each other out of
the windows of their nice
uh you know the penthouse apartment i
don't remember exactly where the odd
couple
where it was someplace pretty nice in in
new york city
so these things have need for each other
and
he goes on and he says something really
interesting and
this is good to keep in mind he talks
here about traditions
when we're thinking we are not just
thinking by ourselves
as purely isolated individual
human beings like it or not we are
thinking
with all sorts of things that have come
to us from other people
in this case we're thinking through
unamuno if you read his book you find
he's referring to all these other
thinkers and writers and and other
historical people because they've made
some sort of impact
so we can talk about traditions and he
tells us
that a purely rationalist tradition
is impo is as impossible as a tradition
purely religious now you could say well
that leaves a lot open
maybe they're both possible maybe maybe
he's saying that
neither one is impossible no he's
actually saying
both of them are impossible you never
ever
ever get something that is purely
rationalist
you never get something that is purely
religious
or non-rationalist they're always mixed
in together
this also goes for philosophical
movements like empiricism
and rationalism right you you know
if you look at descartes as jill so has
pointed out
uh in in a work there's so much that
he's actually borrowing from previous
thinkers some of which is arguably
empiricist
if you look at lock there's all this
rationalism
in him you know people who say that
they're pure idealists or pure
materialists to use another opposition
neither one is entirely pure
when it comes to these traditions so no
more than the individual
completely falls on one side or the
other however
much hypertrophism may happen on one
part of them that doesn't happen
in traditions of thoughts or movements
or schools or approaches
either as he points out it's frequently
disputed whether the
reformation was born as the child of the
renaissance or as a protest against
it and he says both are true the son is
always born as a protest against the
father
right and he gives you some some you
know arguments about that
the other thing that he says that's
particularly relevant to this is
passionate doubt
is he says that every position
of permanent agreement or harmony
between reason and life
between philosophy and religion becomes
impossible
and the tragic history of human thought
is simply the history of a struggle
between reason and life
reason bent on rationalizing life and
forcing it to submit to the inevitable
to mortality life bent on vitalizing
reason forcing it to serve as a support
for its own vital desires
this is the history of philosophy
inseparable from the history
of religion so
this is an important point here there's
two things really going on there he's
saying listen
you're always going to have a ad mixture
of these two and they're always going to
be in some conflict
notice what he says here let's be really
careful about the terminology
every position of permanent agreement or
harmony
between these these two polarities let's
call them
permanent there is no permanent
harmonizing these things it always
breaks down
whether in the individual or within the
movement
or school or tradition of thought
you can't really have a permanent
agreement you also can't have lines of
demarcation that say
theology faith you be on this side
philosophy science you'll be on this
side
and then there'll be this nice you know
border you could say well who drew the
border
right and the border is always
continually being crossed
and so we we can't get away from these
mixtures
you're not going to have a harmony
you're not going to have
even just an entire you know all the
time conflict there's going to be
collaborations between them
and this is going to happen in us and
this is going to mean
that we are still within a position of
doubt
is it just purely intellectual doubt
or is it passionate doubt does it
involve us
in our commitments of the will in our
feelings our sentiments
which could be anguish which could be
sorrow which could be exaltation
which could be the entire panoply of our
aff activities
doubt itself can be understood
as something that is a sort of passion
as well gnawing continually at us
unamuno thinks that this is something
that we should
embrace that we should
view as an integral part of the tragic
sense of life
you